my neighbor his fifth cousin twice
removed gardener heard from his dentist
that Brett Kavanaugh convinced Ted
Cruz's dad to murder JFK in the
mid-1980s and I can confirm that my
neighbor is very credible another report
we're just getting this in right now
it's coming from a very credible source
Ronan Feinstein that count Bohuslav
chotek von Schaack co-owned voguing
recall seeing Brett Kavanaugh at
Sarajevo in 1914 and of course we are
now calling for a full CIA investigation
for this very credible evidence that
Brett Kavanaugh may have started World
War one and in one final devastating
report this morning which I should add
is very credible allegations emerged
that Brett Kavanaugh helped Flavius
Odoacer overthrow the Emperor Romulus
and topple the western roman empire
sometime in the mid 1980s and Colter
will help us break down all of these
allegations then Deputy Attorney General
Rod Rosenstein may or may not be fired
today Michael Moore's movie bombs and
because all nature is but art unknown to
thee the Supreme Court is founded on
this day in history
Michael Knowles and this is the Michael
Knowles show
[Music]
so much to cover who knew that the
Western Roman Empire fell in the
mid-1980s when Fred Cavanaugh is at
Georgetown Prep School wow that was the
great crimes of history all ode to
Georgetown Prep
and Yale we'll get to the Yale of it all
and why everyone seems to be getting
naked at Yale before we do that speaking
of getting naked verbal mattress baby
you know how much I love purple mattress
come into my boudoir come into my
boudoir before Ronan Farrow ruins my
career because of something I did in
1982 I love purple mattress you know
this I actually do have trouble sleeping
at night I don't I you know I've always
I've always gotten nice mattresses you
know the spring mattress or the memory
foam whatever yeah but I still wake up
with crooks and my back hurts and my
neck hurts purple mattress is
categorically different and better than
other mattresses this is because it uses
a brand new material that was developed
by an actual rocket scientist you know
me I'm a man of simple tastes I'm easily
satisfied by the best this is the best
it's both firm and soft at the same time
that sounds impossible but it's an out
with purple mattress it also sleeps
really cool as a man of Sicilian descent
I can get a little moist a little oily
in the night and this really helps so it
says you're a gravity hundred night
risk-free trial if you're not satisfied
return for a full refund 10-year
warranty free shipping and returns free
in-home setup and old mattress removal
they might as well give you a back
massage while they're at it
you're gonna love purple right now my
listeners get a free purple pillow with
the purchase of a mattress that's in
addition to other great free gifts on
the website go to purple comm use promo
code cough FAC OV e fe fe verbal comm
promo code cough fac o VF e fe the only
way to get the free pillow and to bother
been is to go to use my promo code cough
fa co v fe fe a check out purple comm
promo code cough fa okay i want to tell
you in this whole storm cloud of the
Brett Kavanaugh allegations in all of
the it's such hacker e it's such an
abuse of the public trust it's such an
abuse of an important institution or in
the in the midst of all of that storm
cloud there is a silver lining which is
that apparently Brett Cavanaugh has
cured Alzheimer's disease and that's a
wonderful thing that's a march forward
for science
a great move for our government because
of memories that had been repressed not
for just a couple weeks or a few months
or years decades many decades in some
cases they are being dredged up now all
of a sudden by that little smile on
Brett Kavanaugh is faced by the thought
that we're going to have a Supreme Court
justice who reads the Constitution and
interprets it to mean what it actually
means you've probably read about the
allegations they are insane I might look
a little tired today because they broke
last night and I was up until 2:00 2:30
in the morning
reading through this insanity so let's
begin with the least insane allegations
which also are totally baseless Ronan
Farrow dredged up this woman from Yale
Deborah Ramirez by the way I log in to
Twitter last night and I see Yale as
trending and I've known since 2015 when
that shrieking girl humiliated that
entire University and whenever I see
Yale trending it's not a good thing it's
not I opened it up as oh here we go the
allegation is that Brett Kavanaugh was
at a party in Lawrence Hall on Yale's
old campus when he was a freshman and
everybody was drinking and the
allegation it's not even really quite
being made because even the woman who's
accusing Rhett Cavanaugh says she's not
sure if it happened but the allegation
is that he unzipped his pants whipped
out the you know Brett junior and they
all laughed about it but they don't
really no one really remembers because
everyone was drunk including the woman
who's accusing him and I tell you I've
been to a lot of parties in Lawrence
Hall and old campus and I wish 'men year
end even later and of all the parties
that I was ever at on yells old campus
never once did a federal judge expose
himself to me
so that's evidence on the other side of
that it's evidence at least as weighty
as the as the Deborah Ramirez almost
allegations so there by the way the
reason I'm using language carefully here
is she doesn't know what happened she
says she does I don't really know I
don't really know what happened so then
the New Yorker could not find one
eyewitness to corroborate this story
there was a woman that Ramirez says was
at the party who then they reach
and the woman said now there's no I
wasn't at that party have no memory of
that Ramirez
even today even after she's made this
allegation has said she's not sure if
it's him
her Ramirez his best friend freshman
year and throughout her time at Yale has
said she never heard anything about it
Ramirez is a registered Democrat she's a
left-wing activist doesn't prove
anything per se but it does add a lot of
context also Ramirez admits that she was
totally hammered at this party and by
the way is someone who has been to a lot
of Yale parties I'll say people do drink
a ton there it is free-flowing all over
campus but she says she doesn't really
remember what happened and her other
friend says she never mentioned it once
until now as for the allegation itself
again a lot of people are saying this
never happened there's no way this ever
happened I will say Yale does have a lot
of nudity going on they do there's
streaking there naked parties so there
is a there it there is a lot of nudity
here but you've got to remember no one
brought up any allegation like this
until five minutes ago until until five
minutes ago it's not like Brett
Kavanaugh with some unknown entity he he
became a Farris somewhat public figure
during the Ken Starr investigation he
was working under Ken Starr to
investigate Bill Clinton he then was
working in the Bush administration and a
pretty front-facing role he then became
a federal judge in 2006 he's then he's
been up on Supreme Court lists for a
while and none of this came out anywhere
until not only the 11th hour of the
confirmation hearing this time but until
after the Christine Ford allegations
started to fizzle this came out of no
sir it's just really hard to believe now
that the story comes from Ronan Farrow
and Jane Mayer who wrote this piece in
The New Yorker
here it look Rana Farrow has done good
work before but this one is really sad
this is really tarnishing his
credibility and here's Jane Mayer
describing all her great evidence that
she's got on CBS Jane the corroborating
witness which who says has all the
details including Cavanaugh's name where
did that witness come from and where did
that witness get the information about
this from if that person doesn't know
Ramirez he remembers it from from
he was in the same dorm same same little
building on Yale's old campus and he
remembers it clearly I asked him you
know be very careful no I such said he
heard it from someone who was there and
as I've said we interviewed him and I
said to him are you sure that it was
Brett Kavanaugh he said I am a hundred
percent sure but he was not at the party
cheap
was he there well no he wasn't there I
told you it wasn't there but he like
lived nearby or something
well okay did he know and actually Jayne
Meyers defense here for her corroborate
she called him a corroborating witness
Oh was he a witness though no he wasn't
a witness okay so any isn't
corroborating anything said yeah well
okay he didn't see it and he can't
attest to it but he heard about it like
from some guy who knew the guy or this
or that but I'll but let me tell you I'm
such a good journalist I asked him I
said are you sure are you and he said
he's sure so look don't don't knock me
I'm a journalist I asked him I asked him
are you sure he said he sure that's
journalist that's journalism today in
the me to movement really sad because
Ronan Farrow has done great work before
but this is so pathetic this is so
pathetic that other news outlets turned
it down
the New York Times turn this story down
NBC turned this story down even the
Washington Post which has zero standards
left even they turned it down why
because this isn't a news story this is
not responsible journalism this is
reckless this is a smear you could do
this about anybody you could say this
about anybody but so that's just the
first allegation that's just the first
one how do we know that this one is not
credible because of everything about it
if the New York Times is going to turn
it down for the Washington Post is going
to turn down an opportunity to attack
president Trump's nominee and President
Trump it ain't worth it but then enters
Michael avenatti the creepy porn lawyer
to borrow Tucker Carlson's phrase he's
that guy he's that blowhard who goes on
television and uses uses the hashtag
word basta bus that which is an Italian
word that means enough and I'm taking
bets on whether Michael avenatti speaks
more than one word of Italian I suspect
does not but he's this big or bump up
and he so michael avenatti is now
alleging not that Brett Kavanaugh
whipped it out freshman year at a drunk
party he's not doing he's he's accusing
Brett Kavanaugh of running a gang rape
circle in DC in the 80s or something
he's alleging that Brett Kavanaugh is
this like secret Don pimp gangster who
was running up apparently a brothel for
men to go in and abuse women that is not
an exaggeration he he sent emails he's
making this allegation publicly so how
do we know that that story is false
well because Michael avenatti is saying
that if if Michael avenatti told me that
two plus two equals four I would deny
mathematical reality because that guy
has zero honesty is zero credibility and
zero integrity how else do it well how
do we know that the gang rape thing is
not true it's because it's facially
absurd it's absurd on its face but the
other the other reason that we know that
all of these are not credible
allegations is the timing so if the
Democrats had the kristine forward
allegation as early as late July and now
they've had this allegation for five
minutes and which and it only came out
after the Christine Ford thing fizzled
but even the Christine Ford allegation
why are we only getting that now why
didn't we get that in July because in
July the Democrats when they're trying
to target Cavanaugh they came out and
said that he bought baseball tickets for
his friends on his credit card and then
he paid his credit card bills off
overtime those were the big scandals
that they were gonna get Brett Cavanaugh
on he has friends and likes America's
pastime and pays his bills he even
bought some apple pies on that credit
card and then paid it off on time so
that was their first attack if they
really took this seriously right now
trending on Twitter is the fridge
believe survivors believe women and will
and by the way we'll get to in a little
bit why due process is a much more
important hashtag than than believe
survivors well we'll get to that later
on in the show
after we talked to Ann Coulter who has a
typically colorful take on all of this
but but you know if they really believed
this if they really thought Christine
Ford was a serious credible witness they
really believed that Brett Kavanaugh
whipped it out at a party freshman year
in Laurens Hall on old campus if they
really believed that he were running
some kind of criminal gang rape brothel
enterprise as Michael avenatti the least
serious person in America is now
alleging if they really believe that
they would have brought it up at the
time but they didn't they thought they
could take him down on baseball tickets
and credit cards and then they thought
this and then this it's just a
methodical hack attack before we explain
why it is so important to defend Brett
Kavanaugh why this is a truly world
historical moment a turning-point moment
at least for the Republican Party let's
bring on Ian Coulter to get her
perspective she brought up a great
article the other day you know I read
her column every week and she she said
that Haven Monahan was going to testify
at the Cavanaugh hearings and for those
who don't remember Haven Monahan was the
figure in the gang rape case allegedly
at UVA that Rolling Stone reported on
and the only trouble is Haven Monahan
was a totally fictitious character
invented by the accuser who made up the
whole story so that was that was her
take there I spoke to an a couple days
ago let's let's turn to that and see
what you had to say and thank you for
being here good to be here Michael so
Ann you've got a lot of explaining to do
because you were early on a supporter of
Brett Kavanaugh I always take your
advice I always follow your lead and now
we have found out that's the president
yeah I try to follow his lead too but
we'll get to that in a second but now we
found out Ann that Brett Kavanaugh is
actually secretly a super-duper
convicted rapist how do you answer for
yourself no I totally love this the only
even I mean obviously he didn't do it
she's a deranged lunatic but even what
she is alleging what she's actually
alleging is some guy let's say
drunkenly groped her in high school
everything else is as usual with
feminists a product of her imagination I
thought he might inadvertently kill me I
thought it was going to be an attempted
rape well okay you could think he was
going to turn into Bigfoot but that's in
your head that is quite a leap actually
happen it's quite a leap from the grow
thing to the attempted manslaughter that
was I don't know where that that's right
yes and I suspect being most charitable
to her
I mean I've noticed this a lot public
figures um
people's memories are not as good as
they as they imagined them to be and the
more they think they have a great memory
the the worse it is I I apparently dated
every boy on North Campus at Cornell you
can't believe how many people it has
come back to me that I dated not me and
I keep you know I keep telling people
that you and I dated but nobody believes
me and III don't think they're there
they're like bragging I think their
memories get confused because I've had
at least in one case a guy say this
directly to me on the street and I never
dated him Michael well and other stories
come back to me an argument I allegedly
had that was and I was being portrayed
perfectly favorably uh but so funny she
got an argument Yale Camus are at Yale
Law School I never took a class with
Yale campus or I'm glad you have that
fond memory of me being so clever and
witty but it wasn't me so this happens a
lot were P something they super people I
think in people's memories they
superimposed some public figure whom
they knew at an earlier time on some
other memory so when Cavanaugh came back
emphatically saying I was not at that
party this did not happen that's kind of
a ballsy thing to do instead of saying
the way you and I began this
conversation Oh give me a break
seventeen-year-old gets drunk and gropes
a girl first time ever unprecedented
please PLEASE present another girl who
isn't an hysterical feminist who who is
womb a that hasn't happened to and be
actual
chaos or even remember that but he
didn't say that he didn't say I was 17
I'm a different man and in general when
you're accused of something I think it's
much better to say yes I did it but it
was consensual and not I was never in
Cleveland but anybody saw you in
Cleveland you're screwed
he came back and fatica Lee saying I was
never in Cleveland I think that pushed
her back on her heels much like the boy
who came up to me on the street and
claimed he dated me and I said no you
didn't I think it sort of shocked them
when you're emphatic that way and they
think to themselves oh my gosh did I get
this wrong was this somebody else that's
what happened but her handlers and her
lawyers so she's saying I got it wrong I
can't testify they're saying shut up
we'll handle this that's right why we
keep getting these endless BS offers
about you know that the the terms under
which she will test Monday or it's
Thursday and the FBI and the CIA is
going to be there how is this going to
end or because I think some Republicans
some squishy people are saying oh well
we can move on we can get another
nominee if we have to he's we can't do
it I mean it it is this or nothing yes
yes no that would be very bad I mean
that means that I do not think the
founding fathers when they wrote the
Constitution were just in so much of a
rush they forgot to include the part in
the advice and consent Clause where
random psychology professors at Palo
Alto
get a veto you missed that you know if
they if they if they get this guy if
they say that okay because of a 36 year
old alligator
what are we going to get what judge
could we ever get through what a
studious unimpeachable white guy will
ever be able to hold office again no it
will be fair game on white men in in any
walk of life don't worry no allegations
necessary or rather no evidence no
corroboration no even really believable
ability to the story I mean she doesn't
remember what year it happened she
doesn't remember where it happened I do
yes but
she wants an investigation what on earth
would an investigation look like here
I'll just go around to every house in
Montgomery County were you ever at
something resembling a party yeah did
you have a party in this house did you
did you ever see a sort of preppy
looking white boy a teenager running
around the greater DC area to do now I
want to move on because I know we've
only got a little bit of time because I
read your column religiously I and you
have been reminding yeah what you've
been reminding all of us that we don't
have a wall yet where is this wall yes
there's no way back you see this is why
this is part of the reason I wrote
resistance is futile I'm trying to
direct the left to a much better attack
on the president what can I you know
every third day I want to fly to
Washington track down the President and
hold his head underwater until the
bubbles stop and then the resistance
brings me back they want some utterly
unprovoked unfair attack they run off on
their demented international Russian
conspiracy theory yes this bumbling
buffoon staged the most massive
international conspiracy boris and
Natasha
he's boris and Natasha all rolled up
into one
yeah that's right yes yes exactly and so
does the Cavanaugh stuff they drove me
back into his arms when I'm really kind
of mad at him and I I mean there are
many there are many weird aspects to the
resistance a military term that if
companies had he lost the Hillary oh my
gosh it would have been a dog whistle
for the KKK right military term he's
activating the militias and in fact we
Trump voters and supporters have been
subjected to massive physical violence
by auntie Fah and and I mean we are
witnessing a fascist uprising man if the
shoe were on the other foot I think we
might notice that um but if the
resistance one of it one of the
unfortunate things I think we're seeing
it with Cavanaugh
um with the resistance is I mean they've
given up all kinds of principles that
they've held for decades and decades and
decades like you know the Russians love
their children too when during Stalinist
show trials now they're just an
ordinarily corrupt government that's
right when they were going to blow up
the world that was a different matter
yeah exactly exactly but one of them is
I mean it used to be not just it wasn't
just just me talking about illegal
immigrants driving down the
working-classes wage screwing over
America I mean it used to be Jesse
Jackson standing at the border demanding
demanding an end to illegal immigration
um it used to be Harry Reid on the
Senate floor saying the concept of
anchor babies is insane used to be
Dianne Feinstein and Barbara Boxer
amazingly enough defending the border
patrol for whacking illegals running
across the border so I mean it it may
have happened in the Democratic Party
anyway they were kind of going in the
direction of not caring about the
working class or or you know flyover
people and just a screw we've we've got
the actresses we've got Wall Street
we've got the identity politics eyes on
the immigrants but it would be really
helpful if if both parties could get
together and care about the people who
already live here
and if the resistance who read my boat
they would see the way to go after Trump
is to attack them for not fulfilling his
promises to say look we actually do care
about the working class but no we can't
do that because if Trump is for it
they're against it mm-hmm that's right
and and their philosophy your books
it's amazing that your opponents don't
read your books because the books they
always have colorful titles and they
include incredible insight you know
resistance is futile obviously
adios America has so much on immigration
eeep Laurie bus awesome in Trump We
Trust gave a great argument that Trump
was elected because of policy the left
thinks he was elected because he's a
main guy and he tweets things on on that
point you know do you see going into the
midterms looking at 2020 how is it
looking how is it looking for the left
are they gonna understand this lesson or
are they gonna change their ways are
they going to make it
to the American people or are we still
safe because of the policy preferences
of the American people I think
Trampas is it's weird I think he tends
to be safe for re-election I'm not sure
about the midterms the the history
suggests there will be a blue wave Trump
hasn't built the wall and I may be the
only one getting snippy with him on
Twitter but I was at a fair conference
in Washington and ran into a lot of
sheriffs and a lot of Angel moms and
they were thanking me for my snippy
tweets I mean a lot of anyways really is
the morale I thank you too and thank you
they won't know I mean specifically on
the wall they want the wall that was the
champ so when your own base is
demoralized I promise you their base
isn't demoralized oh they hate this guy
with the hot hot hate of a thousand suns
I I admit I'm worried about the midterms
and weirdly enough what may save Trump
is how insane the left is ie the
resistance that they were smart they
read my book and they stop being insane
well that's the book everyone else
should go read it to resistance is
futile and I've taken up too much of
your time already so I'll let you go
that is resistance is futile by my
ex-girlfriend and Coulter she doesn't
remember but I'm sure I can jog her
memory and thank you so much for being
here love her love her so and she's so
so right about this and we need to
defend Kavanagh we have to defend
Kavanagh I hope that Republicans aren't
getting squishy on this I hope they're
not thinking oh he's compromised
oh he it's hard and he's dance that now
it's just a new one let's do it they're
gonna say that Amy Kony Barrett exposed
herself to some girl at Yale in 1982
they'll do it to anybody they'll do it
to anybody and I've read this piece
today in The Daily Beast
I you know I wake up every morning and
the way that i roused myself had a bed
as I read some stupid left-wing piece
and so this one I read it is a I'm a
Republican but Cavanaugh must withdraw
his nomination it's in The Daily Beast
is by a woman named Sophia Nelson I
don't know if she's really a Republican
there are some people who say that there
publicans but they never vote Republican
and they hate conservative ideas like
Jennifer Rubin and now at this point
David Frum we'll get to him later and
Anna Navarro same thing so I don't know
Sophia Nelson might be one of those
she said what this is a new day but the
party's leaders seems stuck in a past
century and her entire thesis is that
yeah sure maybe it he didn't do any of
this and yeah but but you know they've
already smeared him so let's just move
on because you know some women have been
sexually harassed by some people at some
point somewhere someplace so we can't
have captain that's what that's her
actual thesis you know it's the
Democrats smear these guys but he's
because he got smeared let's not let's
do someone else it's a horrific argument
it's so so wrong before I rouse you into
your strong necessary support for
brekkie Bono I've got to say goodbye to
Facebook and YouTube I'm sorry we're
gonna analyze some fake hoaxes rape
stories that have been going on as the
hashtag believe all survivors it goes
around the country and but before we do
that go to daily wire comm if you
already there thank you very much you
keep the lights on you keep coffey in my
cup if you're on facebook and youtube
you probably won't be there long so go
to daily wire it's ten bucks a month
$100 for an annual membership you get me
you get the andrew Clavin show you
usually get the Ben Shapiro show that
you don't get it today because of the
Jewish holidays I was thinking man of
men must be thinking right now of all
the days to be Jewish this news cycle
was the roughest what was I thinking you
know because there's a lot that we're
gonna have to cover but usually you get
been you get to ask questions in the
mailbag that's coming up on Thursday so
get your mailbag questions in you have
to ask questions in the conversation I
believe the Lord of the multiverse and
replevin is up next but none of that
matters because you get this sweet sweet
vintage the mmm that you know that's an
older vintage I mean that is an old
vintage vintage has been around for a
long time that is the Diane Feinstein
blend that varietal of leftist ears and
that's gonna be even sweeter it's
already sweet
it's gonna be even sweeter when we push
this guy through nananana and you can't
stop us it is gonna taste it already
taste good but it's gonna taste even
better than so make sure you get your
leftist tears by the time we do that go
to daily wire calm we'll be right back
hashtag believed survivors is trending
was the top trend on Twitter just an
hour ago
hashtag due process has not been
trending at all but that's a very scary
thing because if we just believe all
accusations regardless of evidence
regardless of time frames people's
rights are going to be trampled people's
lives are gonna be ruined people are
gonna be smeared and mere anarchy will
be loosed upon the world Oh a lot of
people ask they say why would a woman
make a false accusation of sexual
harassment like Anita Hill did to
Clarence Thomas at the 1991 confirmation
hearings of exposure or sexual assault
or whatever like we're getting now why
would a woman make a false accusation
the short answer is I don't know but
they do and the longer answer is there
are a couple reasons which we've seen in
recent years in 2014 the uva rape case
the gang rape case covered in rolling
stone wall-to-wall coverage this girl
said she was raped at a fraternity at
uva turned out it was totally bogus
it was totally bogus she we found out
later she completely made it up and she
actually made up some of the people in
it she made up the guy Haven Monahan who
was one of the one of the perpetrators
there 2014 why did she do it I don't
know couldn't tell you Morgan triplet in
2013 she reported that she had been
raped and people took it seriously major
investigation turned out she had posted
an ad on Craigslist begging first she
begged a guy to shoot her in the
shoulder nobody took no apparently no
one wanted to do that that wasn't
appealing then she posted an
advertisement asking a guy to beat her
up and have sex with her and a
apparently a couple guys jumped on that
one so they met up with her beat her up
did whatever they did and then she
looked and her cell phone screen said
I'm not beating up enough punch me more
and then she reported that she had been
raped why did she do that
because she was a Looney tune a complete
wackadoodle I can't explain that I can't
give you a rational explanation for that
but she was a nut a dezirian all who was
the president of her local chapter of
the National Organization for Women at
Rollins College same thing happened a
few years ago
reported a rape and it was a hoax 2013
meg lank or Simon's at the University of
Wyoming total hoax 2009 Dan male nude on
yay of Hofstra University accused men of
gang raping her in a bathroom stole it
later came out they found out that it
was totally consensual and she accused
them of gang rape in that case because
she didn't want her boyfriend to find
out that she had voluntary sex with
other men she her boyfriend accused her
said you look like you've just had sex
with a bunch of people she said oh I do
i I was you know and she made this false
accusation of course Duke Lacrosse who
can forget the Duke Lacrosse case ruined
those boys lives
overzealous prosecutor and it turned out
that it was totally fabricated in 2013
tonya barrace at the University of
Florida she said that she was raped
there was an investigation it was a
total hoax why did she do it she said
quote she wanted to teach a lesson to
women in the area then an attack could
happen to them so in that case the hoax
was prompted by feminism or by a fear
for a narrative that didn't really exist
but she wanted to prove existed and this
you hear this all the time with the left
when you disprove one of their hoaxes
they say yes that was false but it
proves a larger truth there is a larger
truth you say no there's not a larger
than what larger than the lie you told
you anything's larger a larger truth and
the lie that you just told they always
say never mind the particular it's the
narrative that's the abstract narrative
has to be true and and of course of
course Duke Lacrosse so why would a
woman make something up I don't know to
advance a narrative because of her
feminist ideals because of boyfriend
caught her I don't know those are just
those are particular examples that I can
point to in very recent history now does
this mean that women are always making
up allegations or that they're
frequently making up allegations no and
it's awful and it's a hard crime to
prove so you should take women very very
seriously when they make this this is
part of the reason why these allegations
should not be investigated by campus
tribunals of boards of professors or by
hack senators who are trying to torpedo
an unimpeachable
in court nominee they should be
investigated at the time that they occur
by law enforcement and the perpetrators
if they're found to be perpetrators
should be hung up by their neck they
should they should be have the book
thrown at them and probably be executed
but you can't execute people either if
they're live actually execute them or
kill their reputations based on baseless
allegations 36 years later you cannot do
that Brett Kavanaugh must go through let
me say it again in case you didn't hear
in case you were a little squishy Brett
Kavanaugh must be seated on the Supreme
Court if they fail to confirm Brett
Kavanaugh there there is no argument for
electing Republicans because they won't
stand up to even the flimsiest attacks
it means they can't do nothing even when
they got the house even when they got
the Senate even when they've got the
White House even when they've got
textualist on the Supreme Court they
can't do nothing so why would you ever
vote for them this is so important I
think you know some people are trying to
make the case oh it doesn't look well we
still have the Senate let's just put
someone else through let's just do it
doesn't really matter Kevin all it's too
bad what happened to him but it's like
okay whatever no if it didn't matter
they wouldn't be pushing this hard if it
didn't matter the Democrats wouldn't be
pulling out every flimsy filthy lie that
they've got every smear that they've
been working on since 1987 when they
first did this to Bork they Ted Kennedy
that degenerate smeared him smeared a
good man and a great jurist on a man who
should have been on the court they did
it again to Clarence Thomas in 91 four
years later because they didn't have
their fill they do it every single
chance that they can get we cannot let
this happen if people talk about a blue
wave yeah I don't think you're gonna get
a blue wave right now
if you don't let this guy through you
are gonna get a blue tsunami you're
gonna get a blue tidal wave because
there will be no reason to elect
Republicans not a single one this is a
blood sport it's been going on for
decades old allegations we saw the
decades-old crime in 1987 when they
torpedoed judge Bork and this this has
been building for a very very long time
it's an
a brutal knuckle fight we should pummel
them over the rhetorical head that vote
should have happened a week ago or two
weeks ago no hearings no investigations
nothing you are not entitled to that 36
years later with flimsy nothing no
witness we know actually in the Ronan
Farrow piece Democrats came hunting for
them came hunting to try to dig up
anything the woman in the Ronan Farrow
piece
Ramirez said I don't remember I don't
remember if it was Cavanaugh I don't
really remember any details and six days
later she said okay I remember now yeah
I was him as six days after Democrat
vultures were picking at her corpse
it's disgusting there should be nobody
should give this any quarter in
Cavanaugh thank goodness we have
Cavanaugh
because Cavanaugh is like really really
Manning up here he said he sent a letter
to the Judiciary Committee he said he
will not be intimidated into withdrawing
if ain't going to happen he's going to
defend his good name and the good
reputation that he has built up for a
long time this is making me feel hopeful
and I hope that Republicans circle the
troops around and stand firm on this for
reaction we turn to King Henry the fifth
of England
we view
[Music]
we happy few we band of brothers for he
today that sheds his blood with me shall
be my brother be he ne'er so vile this
day shall gentle his condition and
gentlemen in England now Abed shall
think themselves accursed they were not
here
[Music]
cheap whiles any speaks that fought with
us
[Music]
huzzah yes gentlemen of America Nellis
sleep now I bed absolutely right well
said King Henry also now coming at Brian
carome of CNN Sentinel newspapers he's
saying that investigators this was a
major report got a zillion retweets said
investigators now in Maryland are
looking into another Cavanaugh
allegation investigators in Maryland in
this county okay so then other
newspapers called up the Chief of Police
and said is that true or investigators
looking into this chief - chief police
said nope no they're not
so then Brian Karam says oh well I hope
you don't think I meant the cops oh no
I'm not talking about oh you thought
just because I said investigators you
thought I was talking about
investigators no yeah I see how you can
make that mistake I was talking about
some random guys somewhere not invest
ice you heard investigators and you
thought that meant investigators but
that's not true it's an out-and-out lie
it's an out-and-out lie by a guy who
runs a bunch of newspapers and goes on
CNN and it's an out-and-out lie you
don't care that it's a lie who cares if
someone is making an allegation out of
revenge if they're making an allegation
to get a little bit of attention if
they're making an allegation because
they genuinely think something's true
and but maybe you're mistaken about it
if they're making it who knows why
someone makes an allegation 36 years
later what the effect of it is is to
torpedo a good man's career torpedo a
guy who should be in the Supreme Court
don't give it any quarter don't Brian
carome he responded to me when I pointed
out that he's a liar on Twitter he said
I didn't lie iced investigators you know
it's done it soaked up but now he's a
lot of people are defending him and
saying that was just wordplay he said an
investigator could mean anything and I
don't know it's looking into okay what
no it's a lie it's a lie I get that it's
wordplay too but it's a lot I can say I
heard Brian Karam is a rapist and that
statement is true the statement I heard
Brian kerim is a rapist is a true
statement because I just said it and I
heard him I said it I can hear my own
voice consequently I heard that that is
true so I could say that now if I
reported that
I would be a dirty rotten liar because
the clear implication of what I've said
is egregiously misleading and baseless
this so I would be a liar but oh but
it's wordplay it's to it no it's not
it's a lie it's a dirty lying we should
call it out for what it is these sorts
of lies speaking of bad reporting by the
way I know we've got to go and we didn't
get to any stories today but too bad we
had a lot to talk about but speaking of
unclear reporting it broke news this
morning that rod Rosen Stein the Deputy
Attorney General was out at the FBI or
at the I'm sorry at the Department of
Justice that he was being fired or he
had resigned or is being called in to
Kelly and that he's out and so then in
that case the Solicitor General of the
United States
is going to come into his his place and
oversee the Muller investigation a
nutria nutria do so then he goes and
meets with general Kelly at the White
House and now it seems that he's not
fired it seems that he's still on the
job why was he possibly gonna be fired
because it came out that he had talked
in a room with Lisa Paige I believe was
there Andy McCabe had said that he
wasn't he would wear a wire
and thought that the 25th amendment
should be invoked to kick Donald Trump
out of office now another source in this
room in that room
said that he was just joking you don't
get to make those jokes at this time you
don't get to make those jokes when
you're a senior official who's
overseeing a highly politicized
investigation that has employed people
who have said that they're going to
subvert the election of the American
people's election of Donald Trump and
try to kick him out of office and
prevent him from being president you
don't get to see that when there were
attacks calls for impeachment you don't
get to joke about those things if that's
the case so anyway he was brought in and
now and he's apparently still on the job
he was at a meeting later and in his
official capacity and but by the time
that it was reported that maybe he was
gonna get fired
David Frum former conservative David
Frum who's now a pearl clutching at the
Atlantic he wrote a piece and published
it titled Rosen Stein's departure is a
national emergency and said quote
special counsel Robert Mulder's
investigation is now in mortal
Harel and therefore you know this is a
national emergency for the United States
so first of all this is kind of awkward
for him he pulled the trigger a little
fast here because it seems that
Rosenstein is not fired at least as of
yet but also it's not a national
emergency it's fine it's fine I think
what you meant to say is that it's fine
it's it we have this means look if he
gets fired then the Solicitor General
comes up he oversees the Moller
investigation who cares who cares by the
way the molar investigation into
collusion between Trump and interference
and the Russia they've found no evidence
that Donald Trump colluded with the
Russians to borrow a mostly empty phrase
they've got nothing they've gonna I
should write another book called the
findings of the Moller investigation
that'll be my second bestseller I'll
sell as many copies as the first but
also I do want to point out this
obsession with the executive agencies
the Department of Justice the FBI the
sanctity of these organizations is
totally bizarre
the idea that the FBI is the greatest
most pristine institution in the history
of the country is absurd for decades you
had a cross-dressing bully J Edgar
Hoover spying on Americans at
blackmailing them using the dirty dug up
to keep himself entrenched in power
having power even over presidents that
isn't it that isn't a totally clean
organization and now we know that they
officials there acted inappropriately
politicized the organization used it to
attack who is now a duly elected
president of the United States why the
pearl clutching there we were supposed
to be on guard against these agencies
all of them look there's good work that
they do but we have to be on guard
against all of them their executive
agencies can be encroachments of power
that should be reserved to the people to
the to the legislature so alright we'll
get to Michael Moore tomorrow because
it's kind of funny his movie flopped
spoiler alert is movie flopped but
because all nature is but art unknown
today I will point out that on this day
in history in 1789 the Supreme Court was
established it actually was founded
today by the Judiciary Act of 1789 and
were in the midst of this disgusting
despicable fight that Democrats started
they started at decades ago but they
doing it is 100% their fault that this
happens that we have to tune in to watch
a confirmation hearing for a federal
judge and hear about disgusting tabloid
rumor trash it's their fault and it's
really pathetic when you look back at
what the judiciary used to be because in
1789 the Judiciary Act was passed two
days later all of the appointments that
President Washington had were confirmed
by the Senate two days later initially
there were six judges on the court
this number moved up and down over time
eventually by 1869 the number was
settled at nine as you know President
Roosevelt tried to pack the court didn't
work out and but in those days it was a
bit more serious certainly the Supreme
Court was more serious now we're
listening to a need a hill 2.0 anita
hill two electric boogaloo is even
grosser than the first time and it's
even less substantiate and the first
time and the first time was baseless as
well why is that though why is it such a
knock-down drag-out it's because we've
given away so much power to the court
we've given the court power to legislate
on huge matters to that come to mind
most egregiously obviously Roe vs. Wade
the idea that the framers of the
Constitution somehow enshrined a right
to kill babies in it I don't know where
that is I did haven't read that in any
particular article obviously nobody's
nobody even on the left really seriously
thinks there's a right to abortion in
the Constitution they just decided they
were going to undercut the process of
self-governance and say that we are the
nine robed dictators are going to tell
us how we're going to govern ourselves
and then and then opers fell obergefell
in just a few years ago which invented a
right to gay marriage which invented the
redefinition of marriage to include
monogamous same-sex couples but for some
reason not polygamous same-sex couples
because as the great Romantic poet
Justice Kennedy found there's a right to
intimacy in the Constitution somewhere
at which in which Justice Scalia
ironically pointed out that right to
intimacy obviously would be restricted
by marriage
asked of nearest hippie we're allowing
these nine rogue dictators to be our
romantic poets in to govern us and
that's why it's going to get filthy and
messy and gross that's why I actually
understand why they take it
so seriously because they've used the
left has used the Supreme Court as this
dominating force for imposing their
unpopular will in the American people
for decades and decades so fair enough
they're gonna fight dirty for it this
doesn't mean that we should calm down I
think some squishes want to say Oh
everyone oh the right should calm down
they should play really nice and you
know make sure that they have their
ascots all done up very well and no no
way man the stakes are very very high
here we've got a guy who is says he's
going to interpret the Constitution by
it's meaning when it was ratified and
believe that words have meaning and that
the the piece of paper has meaning and
you've got other people who say I'm
gonna ignore it I'm gonna torch the
Constitution I'm gonna do whatever I
want and pose my will on the people no
wait don't we cannot let them get away
with this it's ugly it's mucky it's
gross but that's what we have to do we
few we happy few we band of brothers
we've got to do it because the stakes
are very very high if you don't think
they're high look at what the Democrats
are pulling out to try to subvert it
okay that's our show we got a lot more
to talk about but do bad and too long
tune in tomorrow and we'll try to cover
everything else I'm sure that there will
be fallout and get your mailbag
questions in for Thursday in the
meantime I'm Michael Knowles this is the
Michael Nolt show I'll see you tomorrow
[Music]
the Michael Nolt show is produced by
seniya Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer
Mathis Glover and our technical producer
is Austin Stevens edited by Jim nickel
audio is mixed by mic core Amina hair
and makeup is by Jeshua alvera the
Michael Knowles show is a daily wire for
word publishing production copyright for
word publishing 2018